sounds like a YouTube news last days we
went to Disneyland
kalila and I because her sisters and
from Philippines yeah honey and the two
kids and the husband Giovanni yeah and
the two kids we went to Disneyland and I
have to say I've been to Disneyland a
thousands of times before that could
quite possibly bet have been my favorite
time at Disneyland why there was
something about there was something
about the two kids because they're from
the Philippines are from Mud Island
they're from Mud Island right City yeah
whatever Mud Island and they don't have
much there they have these Brown rivers
and they have beautiful beautiful trees
and fruits they don't like they don't
have a Disneyland in the Philippines we
don't we had we used to have this thing
called Enchanted Kingdom like back in
the day it's good knock off and we have
a few things in Manila the closest one
is in Hong Kong and we have a Disneyland
in Hong Kong where we I mean there's a
Disneyland in Hawkins two hours flight
away there's a Disneyland in China Hong
Kong the China yeah technically but I
can't say it I don't know why it's done
come to me yeah it's China because when
I was growing up there
yeah and it still belong it would still
belong to all such a Disneyland Russia
because they can go to Hong Kong
everyone has a Disneyland then
technically cuz there's like you know in
Europe they have a dad yeah but it
doesn't quite compare a thing to you
know no eg Chong [ __ ] Disneyland
doesn't compare it's not the same it's
not the same maybe not
and then what is Micky like scared
because he's gonna get eaten by the
Chinese Mickey the mouse
Oh the Chinese eats anything that moves
I always joke if if et was set in China
the movie would be three minutes long
it's done yeah you got et to cook it and
it'd be eaten it would that movie would
be three minutes long
there would be no [ __ ] Mouse doc
anything walking around the [ __ ] Hong
Kong Disneyland
maybe eating yeah they eat anything that
[ __ ] moves they have a [ __ ]
restaurant in China they eat there
specific thing they do is serve animal
penis I'm not surprised what's wrong
with that what is wrong with like lunch
show and like gay it's not only gay it's
in its bestiality you're not sucking it
for pleasure that's what I suck on the
meat
I suck on the meat to absorb the flavor
when you eat my [ __ ] are you doing it
for nourishment no for [ __ ] vitamins
vitamins this podcast is brought some
flowers [ __ ] yeah I had a great time at
Disneyland and then we went over to
California dream and what's up place
called adventure whatever I call it
California Dream I love California
dreamin because um they have a great
ride there that we wrote it's called new
it's new it's called the guardians of
galaxy mm-hmm based on the movie
franchise and I have to say it was a
pleasurable ride it was scary we were
screaming it's basically like the Tower
of Terror but I feel like it's a scarier
but the world that they create recreated
was so awesome but a rocket like talking
to you and all of that oh they're all
talking to you while you're on there
yeah it's but then it has that safe
right
I'm sorry I don't do good with like
g-forces and all of that I was crouched
over yeah my heart was gonna give out
and I'm gonna ask you caelum why was it
the mainly fun for me at Disneyland I
want to know why I know you guys have to
know this about Bobby he okay
you know how when he first got MADtv he
would do laps around the West Covina
mall and hopefully yet recognized by
Mexicans right in Disneyland echo champ
every three steps he takes it's all ho
it's Bobby Lee and he is said he is just
on a high for ten hours straight he is
taking pictures
give wings to anyone I'm with ya like a
wink-wink you know and I'll get ya milk
he doesn't try to be discreet I don't
you know he wants he football photo
shoot right in the middle he wants to be
seen form a line right here yeah I mean
that's what he loves it makes him so
happy and I've never I think but I do it
in a joking way I think no [ __ ] I don't
do it [ __ ] for like you mean my own
soul I do it so I could just rub it into
whoever I'm you know as a joke in front
of my people I'm with I go yeah you know
I mean I do it for laughs I don't do it
for pleasure
feels good a little but I mean he's got
a feel but good I mean I don't blame you
doesn't feel good at all I hate it I
hate it but yeah that was really fun and
then I'm gonna say one last thing about
that day is we went to I don't care what
you say but that restaurant just topped
it off for me what would I have said it
was delicious
I know but yeah i yeah i think that i
think that you're you're not not giving
it what it was it was the best it wasn't
the best it was one of the best tell you
why it wasn't the best and i couldn't
give you a proper assessment of because
I don't eat I'm not eating meat
currently and it was a steak house so I
ordered how could I hear like oh yeah it
was the greatest steak when I wasn't
eating this day
[Music]